[Musique]
il faut savoir qu'il ya eu une
succession de famille qui ont habité et
résider dans ce château ses visiteurs
pourront dire nous y étions à
l'ouverture au public du château du
bouchet patrimoine de la brenne depuis
huit siècles cet édifice célèbre
propriété privée vient de changer de
mains et sera désormais ouvert au public
pour qu'il découvre entre autres la
riche histoire du lieu
ici nous allons emprunter un essai un
escalier du xviie siècle bâtie sur un
but on promontoire de grès rouge
il offre de la terrasse et des tours une
vue incomparable sur 60 km avec en
premier plan
l'étang de la mer rouge autre patrimoine
brel ou les visiteurs sens où le chat
mon père a été emprisonné dans ce
château et il a réussi à s'échapper pour
ne pas partir en allemagne donc jeu
comme j'ai appris que c'était maintenant
vous pouvez visiter
donc voilà je vous envie de voir ce très
joli du c'est un plaisir de pouvoir
visiter maintenant alors qu'avant
c'était c'était plutôt privé qui s'était
presque j'ai compris pour les journées
du patrimoine on pouvait le voir une
icône gay là c'était l'occasion rêvée de
le faire il ne reste pas grand-chose de
glorieux passé du lieu dans les pièces à
moitié vide
juste quelques points forts pour
l'évoquer un vaste chantier de
rénovation va débuter cet été pour
redonner à la partie 17e les châteaux
son lustre et les meubles d'antan mais
le propriétaire à d'autres projets pour
faire vivre le lieu
il est prévu notamment de mettre à
disposition des pièces aux locataires
donc notamment à une association donc
qui va faire des concerts donc
normalement pour cet été est également
et bien des événements avec la maison du
parc donc tout ce qui est randonnées
pédestres cyclistes et équestres le
château du boucher entend s'inscrire
pleinement dans les activités
touristiques et culturelles de la région
c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour le parc naturel régional de la
brenne